hi I'm Kyle with iFixit and I have here
the HTC 4G Evo this is the very first 4G
phone on the market and we're really
excited about the 4.3 inch diagonal
screen running Android and I'm gonna
take it apart so to get inside we need
to remove the back panel then we can get
to the battery slide your fingernails
around the edge of the phone popping the
tabs and then the back comes off and
then we have this extraordinary red
interior and HTC has branded the battery
okay so I've got the backplate off in
the battery and I need to remove the
micro SD card here and then there are
six Torx screws around the perimeter of
the phone that we have to remove there's
a clever tab mechanism here and as I as
I pop this tab the memory card flips out
and then getting the memory card out is
actually a little tricky if you can do
it with your hands great if not a
tweezers works really well and I've got
my torques t-50 driver out of my bit
driver kit here it's really handy to
have a lot of different bits when you're
taking apart a device like this because
you never know what what sort of weird
screws the manufacturer is gonna throw
at you okay now we've got those screws
removed and there are tabs locking the
mid board in so I'm going to use a pry
tool here to separate the mid board and
as you see as I work my way along I'm
popping tabs free on the plastic frame
it has integrated this clever stand
there's a spring mechanism in here and
it's actually pretty sturdy and then
take a look at the the mainboard here
we've got around the edge we have the
display and USB connectors down here
this is HDMI touchscreen and digitizer
cables here and then this cable is for
the front-facing camera the most obvious
element here is
massive honking 8 megapixel camera
sensor in the top right corner here we
have a small Phillips screw so I'm going
to remove that and then we'll be able to
get the board out okay so now that I've
remove the Phillips screw there I can
actually flip the board off but you got
to be careful because it's still
connected by these these three ribbon
cables over on the side the cable slides
in there and then there's a little black
catch so I'm going to use just a little
plastic pry tool to get into each of
these and pop that catch once it once
I've popped the tab I can just remove
the cable like that now that I've got
those cables removed we can just remove
the entire main board so this is the
display assembly on the front there's
there's glass behind the glass there's a
touchscreen digitizer and then we have
the LCD on the back what I'm going to do
is show you how to remove the glass from
the front if you drop the phone this
ribbon cable we need to pry off it's
just glued down to the LCD now that
that's loose there's adhesive gluing the
glass all the way around you could use a
hair dryer to heat it up
I've already disassembled this so it's
gonna come a little bit easier I'm gonna
start prying this up and I'm just gonna
use a plastic tool like this to get in
between the glass and the LCD and once
you get in there you just want to go
very slowly and pry your way around once
you get the glass free you're all
excited you don't want to game too hard
because you have to route this ribbon
cable through the case now you can see
this is the LCD and then this is your
touchscreen digitizer so that's how they
disassemble the HTC 4G Evo I'm really
excited to have gotten my hands on it
I've gotten to see inside and when you
have yours and you're taking it apart I
would expect it to take you somewhere in
the 30 to 60 minute range if you need
more information any more details on
getting inside we have a lot more
information online fix it calm